l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
d'actualité sur le thème de la crise de
système de santé je rappelle dans ce
débat que le gouvernement
a la faculté si le juge nécessaire de
prendre la parole immédiatement après
chaque orateur pour une durée maximum de
2 minutes l'orateur dispose alors à son
tour d'un droit réparti pour une minute
et le temps de réponse du gouvernement à
l'issue du débat est au maximum de 5
minutes
si vous le souhaitez
madame la ministre répondent après
chaque orateur
vous pourrez donc le faire donc je donne
immédiatement la parole à notre collègue
Patricia shininger pour le groupe du
Rassemblement du démocrate progressiste
n'est indépendant
bonjour bonne année
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous la souhaitons
en masse les premiers janvier nous
trinquons étrangement d'ailleurs en son
nom nous nous rendons compte d'autant
plus que de son importance depuis trois
ans nous savons à quel point elle nous
est précieuse oui la santé et doit
demeurer au coeur de nos politiques
publiques car elle est au coeur de nos
vies nous l'avons dit mais je crois
qu'il faut toujours le répéter et la
épidémie à laquelle nous faisons face
nous le rappelle les professionnels de
santé sont essentiels à notre pays leur
importance est connue de tous les tous
et pourtant le constat demeure alarmant
encore trop de Français sont sans
médecin traitant et trop de
professionnels de santé surmener face à
un flot de patients qui ne baisse pas
encore trop de nos concitoyens mot aux
urgences faute d'accès à un médecin de
garde et trop de service d'urgence
surchargés par des vagues de nu non
nécessaires grâce à cette situation
inquiétante je souhaite rappeler ici que
de nombreuses mesures ont déjà été
prises nous pouvons notamment rappeler
les 19 milliards d'euros investis à
travers le Ségur avec des
revalorisations allant de 180 à 400
euros par mois également l'augmentation
du nombre de places ouvertes aux
infirmiers infirmières la mission flash
urgence répandant pour partie à la
difficulté des services d'urgence le
renforcement des champs de compétences
de plusieurs de nos professionnels de
santé ou encore la montée en puissance
du parcours d'infirmière en pratique
avancée ces mesures ont ainsi pu être
des outils pour penser les plaies de
notre système pour un temps mais les
mouvements de grève nous démontrent
qu'il reste encore beaucoup à faire
plusieurs chantiers nous attendent en
effet et je souhaiterais ici m'arrêter
sur l'un d'eux tout particulièrement
l'enjeu de l'égal accès aux soins
assurer cet égal accès aux soins sur
l'ensemble de nos territoires
nécessitent de répondre à un double
enjeu permettre à chacun de nos
concitoyens de pouvoir être soignés près
de chez lui dès qu'il en ressent le
besoin tout en répondant au surmenage de
nos professionnels de santé un travail
d'équilibriste j'en compte j'en conçois
c'est ce sujet même qui avait motivé la
rédaction d'un rapport avec mon collègue
Philippe mouiller sur les collectivités
à l'épreuve des déserts médicaux
l'innovation territoriale en action dans
celui-ci nous avions proposé des pistes
de réflexion pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins dans les territoires le tout avec
le concours des collectivités
territoriales car elles sont évidemment
centrales dans la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique de santé ambitieuse elles sont
avec leurs élus parmi les premières à
constater et subir les inégalités
géographiques dans l'accès aux soins en
dépit des moyens limités dont elle
disposent en matière de santé elles sont
pourtant nombreuses à mettre en œuvre
des initiatives afin de répondre aux
difficultés d'accès aux soins de leur
administrer création le centre de santé
ou de maison de santé pluridisciplinaire
développement de la médecine ambulante
ou encore de la télémédecine les
collectivités ne manquent pas
d'imagination et de volonté pour
apporter des solutions aux problèmes à
l'accès aux soins plusieurs mesures
présentées par le président lors de ses
vœux bon dans ce sens je pense notamment
à l'amélioration des conditions de vie
de nos soignants afin de renforcer
l'attractivité de ces métiers dans tous
nos territoires je pense également à la
suppression du plafond de 20% des télés
consultations car sans être une solution
unique ce nouveau mode de consultation
représente un outil indiscutable pour
répondre à la pénurie de nos médecins et
notamment de spécialistes dans certains
de nos territoires je pense enfin à
l'engagement pris de permettre aux 600
000 patients atteints de maladies
chroniques d'avoir un médecin traitant
attiré avant de la fin de l'année à
titre pardon le président a également
annoncé vouloir travailler sur les
rendez-vous je m'en félicite ayant
présenté des amendements allant dans ce
sens lors du dernier projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale le
temps médical est précieux et il n'est
pas juste que certains de nos
concitoyens de le gage en ne respectant
pas les rendez-vous pris renforcer le
temps médical de nos médecins nécessite
aussi de faciliter les différentes
tâches administratives qui leur
incomplent ou encore de leur apporter un
soutien nécessaire face à ces mesures un
enjeu d'importance perdure et je sais
qu'il concentre toute notre attention la
permanence des soins je crois
profondément au rôle que pourront avoir
les CPTs dans l'organisation de notre de
cette dernière je crois également que
les professionnels de santé ont leur
rôle à jouer afin de garantir à nos
constituants partout en France un égal
accès aux soins chaque fois qu'ils en
ont besoin aucun Français ne devrait se
sentir désemparé et seul pour prot sa
santé face à une pathologie ou face à
l'imprévu des travaux sont en cours et
je pense évidemment aux nombreuses
discussions qui ont pu avoir lieu au
sein du CNR de santé dans nos
territoires le dialogue la coordination
et la collaboration seront nous
permettre de répondre aux chantiers qui
s'ouvrent à nous pour rassurer cette
égale à accès aux soins madame la
ministre suite au CNR santé et au
concertation quelles sont les premières
solutions que vous pourriez proposer
pour assurer cet égal accès aux soins et
notamment pour assurer la permanence des
soins surtout nos territoires je vous
remercie merci mes chers collègues
Madame le Ministre Souter on va attendre
que le rappeur est rejoint sa place
madame la ministre
monsieur le Président tout d'abord
Mesdames et Messieurs les signatrices et
les sénateurs je tenais l'occasion de
cette première réponse de l'année vous
présenter tous mes vœux et comme vous
l'avez dit et madame la sénatrice une
bonne santé ça va un petit peu nous
aider si nous pouvons tous en très bonne
santé vous répondre en deux minutes à la
grande question que vous m'avez posée
est assez difficile mais puisque il y
aura l'occasion d'avoir plusieurs
questions je vais essayer de répondre au
fur et à mesure de ce débat tout d'abord
tout d'abord où là vous avez commencé
par cela souligner la coordination
nécessaire entre les collectivités les
soignants les élus l'ARS et l'État pour
répondre aux besoins de santé nos
concitoyens de non concitoyens nous
l'avons vu pendant la crise sanitaire à
quel point les collectivités ont apporté
leur aide nécessaire pour pouvoir
notamment répondre à l'enjeu de la
vaccination et cette coordination nous
pensons qu'elle est nécessaire je suis
ministre de l'organisation territoriale
et dans tous mes nombreux déplacements
je vois à quel point la volonté des élus
locaux de participer à l'organisation
des soins à répondre aux besoins de
santé nos concitoyens et fortes et la
nouvelle méthode souhaitée par le
Président de la République c'est celle
là c'est avec les territoires à partir
des territoires et ensemble que nous
répondrons aux besoins de santé de nos
concitoyens c'était l'enjeu du CNR de
conseil national de la refondation plus
de 300 réunions ont eu lieu et nous
sommes en train au ministère de faire la
synthèse puisque le dernier réunion a eu
lieu le 16 décembre et avec le ministre
François Braun nous présenterons fin
janvier début février le résultat de ces
consultations qui viendra qui viendront
compléter les propositions faites par le
Président de la République le vendredi
dernier lors de ses vœux aux acteurs de
la santé mais nous allons pouvoir
ensemble répondre aux besoins de santé
de nos concitoyens à la fois avec la
refondation à l'hôpital mais aussi à la
fois avec la refondation du système de
ville parce que l'un ne marchera pas
sans l'autre c'est une absolue nécessité
et l'enjeu est devant nous mais ensemble
nous allons y arriver
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Bernard jaumier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la miss mes
chers collègues j'imagine que si le
président et le bureau du Sénat nous ont
invité aujourd'hui à débattre de sujets
c'est évidemment eu égard à l'état de
notre système de santé aujourd'hui
beaucoup de Français beaucoup de nos
compatriotes se demandent comment il est
possible que dans un pays qui consacre
55% de ses moyens à la dépense publique
plus 9 points en 20 ans la justice soit
dans un tel état les infrastructures
ferroviaires soient dans un tel état et
le système de santé que nous croyons
jusqu'à quelques années être le meilleur
au monde et en train de s'effondrer à
l'hôpital comme en ville
et bien il faut fournir une réponse car
si on ne fournit pas une réponse on se
trompe dans l'établissement du cadre
politique de réponse
quand on regarde cette dépense publique
qui a progressé de neuf points en 20 ans
et bien en fait
ce qui a progressé ce sont les
transferts vers les ménages et vers les
entreprises c'est plus dix points en 20
ans et le financement des services
publics lui-même a régresser le
financement des services publics dans la
dépense publique ne représentent plus
qu'un tiers de celle-ci et c'est là
l'explication princesse de l'état actuel
de nos services publics et la santé n'a
échappé que très partiellement à cette
évolution car si elle a bénéficié depuis
les années 80 elle duos de 8% dans la
part de dépenses et bien dans le même
temps par exemple la population des plus
de 60 ans qui génère l'essentiel de la
dépense elle elle a progressé de plus
30%
et donc nous consacrons aujourd'hui en
2022 2023 moins de moyens à la santé que
nous en consacrions à la fin du
septennat de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
et quand vous prenez la rémunération des
professionnels inclut ceux qui sont dans
le privé car il y a des acteurs privés
mais le financement vous le savez très
essentiellement public et bien la part
allouée à la rémunération elle elle a
baissé de 2% on part du PIB depuis 1995
alors monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues nous pouvons
entrer dans tous les thèmes importants
et tous les débats importants sur la
gouvernance sur la répartition des
tâches entre les uns et les autres sur
la conception du système tous les points
qu'elle a mis long à lister tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs dans sa question
d'actualité tant que nous resterons dans
ce cadre général nous gerons une pénurie
la maison France sous finance ses
services publics depuis au moins 20 ans
et ça n'a pas changé ces six dernières
années ça continue puisque nous avons
adopté un budget de la Sécurité sociale
qui pour la première fois depuis qu'au
long d'un existent sera inférieur au
niveau de l'inflation en progression ce
sont des faits ils sont incontestables
alors malgré tout il faut se pencher sur
les différents chantiers et j'ai entendu
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt le
chef de l'État
il y a 6 ans j'étais comme un certain
nombre d'entre vous à l'Élysée
et j'ai applaudis à la fin du discours
de l'échelle du chef de l'État qui
présentait ma santé 2022 c'est 10
chantiers prioritaires
et bien lors de son discours de vœux au
professionnel de santé la semaine
dernière
les propositions portées par le chef de
l'État sont les mêmes six ans plus tard
six ans de perdu
la réforme de la T2A elle était déjà
dans ma santé 2022 elle est nécessaire
elle n'a pas été menée et l'épidémie de
covid n'explique pas tout loin de là
il y a donc une nécessité politique de
dire que la santé est une politique
première de notre pays que préserver le
service Santé le service public de santé
c'est préserver un haut niveau de soin
pour nos concitoyens et un égal accès
aux soins et ensuite et ensuite
seulement on pourra discuter de ces
différents thèmes et faire de sorte que
cette discussion ne soit pas une gestion
de pénurie mais impulse un nouvel élan à
la politique de santé dans notre pays je
vous remercie
monsieur le Président
Monsieur sénateur je vais essayer de
répondre à votre à votre question tout
d'abord je vais me permettre de vous
rappeler de chiffres depuis 2017 le
budget consacré à la santé à augmenter
de 53 milliards pour être supérieur à
240 milliards c'est 20% d'augmentation
pour depuis deux PLFSS de projet de loi
de finance de la sécurité sociale de
deux années de suite 0 économie fait sur
le budget de l'hôpital vous avez raison
l'enjeu l'enjeu qui est le nôtre c'est à
la fois de faire en sorte que ces moyens
soient mis au bon endroit pour les
bonnes personnes c'est vraiment l'enjeu
qui est le nôtre l'objectif qui est le
nôtre c'est de fidéliser les soignants
puisque nous savons très bien que par
exemple à l'hôpital ça n'est pas parce
qu'il n'y a pas les moyens que des
fermes c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas de
personnel donc l'enjeu c'est vraiment
fidéliser les soignants c'est rendre les
métiers attractifs et notamment ce qui a
été fait ce qui n'a jamais été fait
c'est un rattrapage sur les salaires
vous l'avez souligné le Ségur a permis
une augmentation avec une enveloppe de
12 milliards pour les salaires des
professionnels soignants de 19 milliards
en investissement en 2018 le président
de la République avait clairement fait
un diagnostic ce qu'il a fait vendredi
dernier à Corbeil-Essonnes c'est pas le
diagnostic c'est la feuille de route le
cap qui nous est tracé avec un objectif
ambitieux et si la réforme de la T2A n'a
pas pu se faire depuis ma santé 2022
c'est que vous n'avez pas oublié
qu'entre temps il y a eu la crise
sanitaire et que les soignants avaient
peut-être autre chose à faire et les
administratifs et autres choses à faire
car est formé le système de financement
de l'hôpital
je vais donner l'apparence à notre
collègue Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues vendredi dernier le
président de la République lors de la
présentation de ces vœux au personnels
de santé a reconnu que notre système de
santé connaissait une crise
multifactorielle qu'il fallait le
réorganiser mais sans moyens
supplémentaires ainsi alors que
l'hôpital est à l'agonie que la médecine
de ville est en grande difficulté aucun
financement exceptionnel ne sera dégagé
par le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron a
acté l'épuisement des soignantes et des
soignants constater que de nombreux
patients n'ont plus de médecins
traitants déplorés que de plus en plus
d'étudiantes et d'étudiants infirmiers
abandonnent leurs études en cours de
route autant de problèmes que nous avons
dénoncé dans cette émission sans que les
ministres aubains ne le prennent en
compte et le président Macron continue
dans la même veine prescrit les mêmes
remèdes qui ont aggravé les mots de
notre système de santé pour répondre à
la grogne des médecins libéraux
notamment concernant le poids de leur
charge administrative il imprime promis
de créer dix nombreuses assistants
médicaux d'ici fin 2024 mais sans
instaurer une régulation à
l'installation il a également misé sur
une forme de récompense pour celles et
ceux qui accepteront de prendre plus de
nouveaux patients quant au garde de nuit
les week-end au lieu de revenir sur le
décret Matéi qui a supprimé en 2002
l'obligation pour tous les médecins d'y
participer il en est resté à des mesures
d'incitation particulièrement
inefficaces je vous rappelle madame la
ministre que notre groupe demande depuis
des années à rétablir cette obligation
de permanence pour les généralistes mais
également pour les spécialistes face aux
nombreuses luttes en cours du côté des
médecins libéraux et des Hospitaliers
des alertes de plus en plus fortes avec
la triple épidémie covid bronchiolite et
grippe ajoutant du désenvoie et de la
colère chez les soignants on aurait pu
espérer que les réponses du président
changent radicalement la donne alors que
les personnels sont épuisés que tout est
tous remettent en cause les conditions
et la charge de travail qui entraîne des
départs hospitaliers en nombre
35 heures serait à l'origine de la
désorganisation de l'hôpital mais
pourquoi ne pas s'interroger madame la
ministre sur le nom d'embauche qui
aurait dû accompagner cette baisse du
temps de travail pensez-vous motiver les
équipes au bout du rouleau en leur
demandant de gérer la pénurie de
personnel les revendications sont sur la
table depuis longtemps revalorisation
des carrières et augmentation des
traitements indiciaires de la fonction
publique moratoire sur les fermetures de
services d'établissements ainsi que sur
les suppressions de lit depuis 2017 21
000 litres d'hospitalisation ont été
supprimés soit 5% des capacités
d'accueil mais surtout il y a urgence à
mettre en place un plan de recrutement
dans le service public hospitalier avec
la création de cent mille emplois comme
le demande les syndicats et les
collectifs de défense de l'hôpital
parallèlement il faut revenir sur le
parcoursup supprimer le numerus à
Perthus et augmenter les capacités de
formation des universités et pour mieux
articuler soit hospitaliers soin de
ville il faut développer
des centres de santé en leur donnant les
moyens nécessaires madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ce qui ressort des
nombreuses auditions qu'on a pu faire à
la commission des affaires sociales
c'est la déshumanisation de l'hôpital et
les réside d'un hôpital entreprises
aussi pour redonner de l'attractivité à
l'hôpital faut-il redonner de la bien
traitance institutionnelle comme le
souligne le docteur Gérard kerzek
médecin urgentiste cela passe outre les
améliorations des conditions de travail
que j'ai déjà évoquées par la mise en
oeuvre de la démocratie sanitaire ainsi
la création d'un tandem administratif et
médical est une mesure positive qui
répond à une demande très forte des
soignants hospitaliers mais il faut
l'accompagner de la suppression des
pôles au profit des services du retour
d'un conseil d'administration avec une
meilleure représentation des personnels
des élus mais aussi des usagers avec
droit de veto sur le budget et aussi
droit de veto sur le projet
d'établissement alors bien sûr qu'il
faut rompre avec la T2A essentiel et
d'arrêter de faire voter un budget de la
Sécurité sociale insuffisant chaque
année car les conséquences nous les
vivons dans la dégradation quotidienne
de l'offre de soins pour toutes et tous
sur l'ensemble du territoire en
conclusion madame la ministre je
voudrais vous poser la question suivante
allez-vous enfin financer l'assurance
maladie à la hauteur des besoins donc
augmenter les recettes au lieu de
réduire les dépenses mettant un mal
l'hôpital et la médecine de ville
merci
Madame le Ministre
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice oui vous avez raison la crise
est multifactorielle c'est bien pour ça
qu'il nous faut absolument refonder
notre système de santé et quand je dis
refonder notre système de santé c'est à
la fois travailler sur l'hôpital mais
aussi sur la ville on nous on n'arrivera
pas à faire en sorte que tout aille bien
si nous on travaille que sur une des
jambes il nous faut absolument
travailler sur à la fois la ville et à
la fois sur l'hôpital je vous le redis
20 % d'augmentation du budget consacré à
la santé depuis 2017 12 milliards pour
l'augmentation des salaires qu'il ne
s'agissait que d'un rattrapage nous en
sommes convenus 19 milliards
d'investissements
décréter qu'il faille embaucher 100 000
personnes oui je vais vous donner un
chiffre l'APHP en 2000 en 2022 à
embaucher 2200 infirmières entre temps
2800 sont partis
l'enjeu l'enjeu je le redis il est à la
fois de mettre en œuvre tous les moyens
pour fidéliser les personnels en place
et de rendre les métiers attractifs
comment fidéliser le personnel en place
vous l'avez dit tout d'abord se
rattrapage sur les salaires qui a eu
lieu cette qualité de vie au travail
qu'il nous faut travailler retravailler
et co-construire ça passe aussi pour
comme l'a dit le président de la
République refaire à l'échelle des
services les emplois du temps et
redonner du sens c'est permettre aux
soignants de rester dans le même service
de ne pas aller peut-être comme certains
le pense et disent boucher les trous
dans le service d'à côté mais c'est
aussi arrêter cette spirale négative et
réussir collectivement aussi à dire que
ce sont des mots métiers donner envie
aux jeunes de s'engager dans ces métiers
de la santé nous le savons tous aussi
qui sont des mots métiers et on leur
donnera envie que si aussi on a un
moment collectivement on arrive à en
parler positivement et puis je le
rappelle que notamment en ce qui
concerne les indemnités de nuit elles
sont prolongées dans le cadre de la
mission d'urgence qui avait été faite
cet été
[Musique]
la ministre mais si vous faites tout
aussi bien que ça et bien notre système
de santé ne serait pas dans l'état dans
lequel il est et puis on va parler
chiffres excusez-moi mais c'est 1,7
milliards de moins pour le budget de de
la santé c'est ça la réalité c'est ça
que vous avez fait voter et quand vous
parlez de l'argent mais l'argent il
existe simplement ce sont les choix
politiques que vous faites pas il y a 70
milliards en moins dans les caisses de
la Sécurité sociale du fait
d'exonération de la des cotisations
patronales et bien c'est là dedans qu'il
faut puiser parce que ça n'est pas
créateur d'emploi ça n'est pas vrai et
moi je vais vous dire les besoins hors
inflex or inflation sont estimées à 10
milliards d'euros supplémentaires pour
la santé donc vous voyez je vous donne
des recettes d'un côté 70 milliards de
l'autre côté 10 milliards mais vous ne
voulez pas faire ce choix là et vous
êtes en train de mettre notre système de
santé à genoux et il y a des personnels
qui sont en souffrance et qui ne se
satisfont pas de vos paroles regarder
tous les mouvements qui se développent
partout
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
les chers collègues l'importance du
sujet de notre débat m'invite à
commencer mes propos par une citation de
William Arthur World le pessimiste se
plaint du vent l'optimiste c'est espère
qu'il a changé et le réalisme ajuste ses
voiles crises des urgences tension
générée par la tripe épidémie du covid
grip et boncolite des programmations de
soins médicaux difficile client de
personnel hospitalier postes vacants
d'émission soignants handburn out la
liste des notes de cette triste mélodie
et bien longue la situation de l'hôpital
continue d'inquiéter dans un contexte
sous la demande augmente du fait de
vieillissement de la population nos
services publics d'urgence connaissent
des sous-effectifs chroniques et restent
sous tension pour faire face à un afflux
important de patients cette situation
inadmissible qui continue à se dégrader
depuis l'été 2022 et le révélateur de la
crise profonde qui traverse notre
système de santé et témoigne du poids
importants de l'hôpital en particulier
l'hôpital public dans la prise en charge
des urgences
l'engagement des urgences résulte d'une
conjonction d'éléments défavorables
d'abord l'accès à une consultation c'est
un médecin généraliste devient de plus
en plus compliqué dans un délai
raisonnable la question du temps médical
disponible continuera de s'aggraver avec
la croissance des départs en retraite
non remplacée ensuite les praticiens ne
s'installe pas de façon géographiquement
harmonieuse le problème des déserts
médicaux et récurrent non seulement en
secteur rural outre-mer mais aussi en
zone urbaine enfin il existe un déficit
d'information sur la conduite à tenir en
cas de problème de santé ainsi de
nombreux patients qui se rendent aux
urgences de leur propre chef le font
faux d'une meilleure orientation il
impose il importe pardon de mettre en
place des mesures alternatives pour
accueillir des soins non programmés afin
de répondre aux besoins des patients
pour un mal qui ne relève pas de
l'urgence vitale comme la petite
bobologie il serait aussi pertinent
d'inciter les médecins de ville
installés dans des maisons de santé de
maintenir une permanence
particulièrement les weekends afin de
pouvoir désengorger les urgences
néanmoins ce dispositif ne peut être
imposé au niveau national dans les
situations sont différentes d'une région
à une autre en revanche les agences
régionales de santé peuvent jouer un
rôle moteur dans différentes
expérimentations je mets cependant en
garde à trop de attendre la voix de
l'obligation de garde finira par
s'imposer au-delà des adaptations du
terrain s'avère nécessaire une meilleure
coordination des soins un meilleur
partage des compétences une meilleure
répartition du pouvoir de décision et
des responsabilités entre médecine de
ville et hospitalisation augmentation
des capacités d'accueil en médecine de
ville accompagnement au travail
collectif développement de la
télémédecine de manière bien encadrée
bien évidemment amélioration de qualité
de vie au travail réduction des pertes
de temps dans les démarches
administratives sont d'autres pistes de
réflexion la pénurie de soignants
d'infirmiers et de médecins risque de
s'installer dans la durée force de
constater que l'augmentation des
salaires prévues dans le cadre de la
santé n'a pas entraîné une nette
l'évolution des recrutements afin de
résoudre le problème de ressources
humaines en santé il est essentiel
d'établir un plan plus riennel mais
chers collègues face à cette crise
aucune solution simple n'existe mais
pour reprendre les mots de Winston
Churchill mieux vaut prendre le
changement par la main avant que nous
vous prennent par la gorge je crois que
c'est fait madame la ministre de notre
retard et significatif n'attendons plus
alors que plus de 6 millions de Français
n'ont pas de médecin traitant une
transformation ambitieuse dans un
système s'impose celle-ci nécessite
l'engagement de toutes les professions
de santé dans une démarche collaborative
pour améliorer l'accès aux soins et
garantir la qualité des pratiques à
l'aube de cette nouvelle année
reconstruisons ensemble notre système de
santé avec mes collègues du groupe Union
Centris je souhaiterais savoir madame la
ministre votre vision réformatrice ainsi
que le plan d'action du gouvernement en
matière de prévention de gestion de
crise pour répondre dans l'urgence
auquel et confronté l'ensemble de notre
système de santé avec ces deux piliers
le public et le privé je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci ma chère collègues
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice 87 % de la France est un
désert médical l'hôpital ne va pas bien
et c'est bien pour ça je le redis je
pense que je vais le redire encore
beaucoup de fois qu'il est nécessaire et
vous l'avez souligné de refonder notre
système de santé à la fois sur la ville
et sur l'hôpital mais à la fois
travailler sur la coordination publique
privée et vous avez bien fait de le
souligner je suis maintenant depuis six
mois j'ai à peu près fait 40
déplacements et des gros déplacements je
peux vous assurer et ce que vous avez
dit est très juste que nous ne pouvons
pas appliquer la même méthode en
Île-de-France qui est le plus gros
désert médical que dans la Drôme où je
suis allé récemment donc c'est bien à
partir des territoires avec les
territoires que nous allons construire
les réponses je suis raisonnablement
optimiste parce que dans les territoires
nous voyons des solutions qui marchent
et vraiment la volonté des
professionnels la résilience des
professionnels il faut le souligner de
tous les professionnels nous rend
j'allais dire optimiste raisonnablement
et va nous vont nous permettre avec la
feuille de route établie par le
Président de la République avec les
solutions qui seront ici du CNR de vous
faire des propositions ce dont nous
sommes convaincus c'est que il nous faut
répartir répartir et c'est tout à fait
vrai dans la permanence des soins la
tâche nous ne pouvons pas laisser à
seulement quelques médecins de supporter
de supporter la permanence des soins il
nous faut co-construire sur le thème de
la responsabilité collective du
gagnant-gagnant et c'est ce qui est en
train d'être le frein notamment dans la
négociation collective avec les médecins
il nous faut répartir la charge de la
permanence des soins c'est ce sur quoi
nous sommes en train de travailler c'est
une des réponses que je peux apporter à
vos nombreuses questions
merci
je lui ai donné maintenant la parole
monsieur Stéphane Ravier pour la Réunion
administrative dessinateurs de figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe
il y a trois minutes je vais la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues selon le préambule
de la Constitution de 1946 la nation
garantie à tous la protection de la
santé mais ça c'était avant pourtant
depuis le début d'une présidente en
marche les Français avaient reçu tant de
promesses dès 2018 le président Macron
présente un grand plan pour la santé
appelé ma santé 2022 sans ces structurer
notre système pour les 50 prochaines
années en 2020 Ségure de la santé en
2021 plan innovation santé 2030 et en
2022 c'est l'annonce brutale de la
refondation d'un système que vous jugez
à bout de souffle notre système de santé
envié par le monde entier et qui a été
saccagé en quelques années car la
réalité de votre politique la voie la
4300 lits fermés à l'hôpital public en
2021 5700 fermés au cœur de la pandémie
en 2020 au total 21 000 lits supprimés
en 5 ans qui viennent s'ajouter au 10000
lits fermés sous François Hollande 37000
sous Nicolas Sarkozy près de 100 000
lits fermés en 20 ans alors que notre
population augmente que son
vieillissement nécessite davantage de
soins et donc de moyens les déserts
médicaux touchent la France sur rurale
mais aussi une partie de la France
urbaine et jusqu'à nos hôpitaux où nous
trouvons porte-close urgences avec un
système qui encourage à faire du chiffre
qui nous promettent plus la qualité de
soins et sort le personnel soignant les
images qui nous viennent de tous les
hôpitaux de France sont déplorables 150
patients serait mort aux urgences faute
de prise en charge depuis début décembre
je vais aussi vous dire Madame le
Ministre des milliers de soignants non
vaccinés viennent de passer leur
deuxième fête de Noël suspendue sans
salaire et sans chômage la France et le
dernier pays européens à ne pas les
avoir réintégrer le dernier vous qui
n'avez le cesse de vous référer en toute
circonstances à nos voisins européens
qu'attendez-vous pour les imiter
je manque de temps pour évoquer les
pénuries enregistrées par l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
conséquences de notre dépendance de la
production étrangère alors en ce début
d'année où nous échangeons des vœux de
bonne santé et je vous les adresses bien
sincèrement Madame le Ministre quels
sont les actions concrètes engagées déjà
par votre gouvernement destiné à creuser
les oasis nécessaires au milieu de ce
désert médical national
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
sénateur
une réponse vous avez parlé beaucoup
d'Europe juste vous dire que puisque
vous regardez ce qui passe ce qui se
passe à côté bah regardez dans quel état
sont les systèmes de santé de nos pays
européens le manque de professionnel est
mondial le manque de professionnels et
mondial on peut pas se satisfaire de
cette réponse mais on ne peut pas dire
non plus que l'herbe est plus verte à
côté regardez ce qui se passe en
Grande-Bretagne regardez ce qui se passe
en Allemagne regardez ce qui se passe en
Espagne et même aux États-Unis le manque
de professionnels de santé et mondiale
il nous faut pour notre pays trouver les
moyens c'est ce que nous faisons et
c'est ce que nous allons faire avec la
feuille de route qui nous a été tracée
par le Président de la République
je suis raviée vous vouliez intervenir
oui oui mais monsieur le Président
simplement écoutez Madame le Ministre
moi j'avoue être humble je suis sénateur
français et c'est le système
médical qui français qui m'intéresse ce
sont nos compatriotes qui m'intéressent
et je ne me contente pas de me dire que
ailleurs c'est pire pour justifier la
situation qui est la nôtre et qui est le
résultat direct des politiques et qui
ont été menées par les gouvernements
français alors un peu d'audace un peu je
dirais de réflexion un peu d'autonomie
et pour que les idées franco-françaises
puissent permettre à notre système de
santé d'évoluer dans une situation vers
une situation positive
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Yves roux pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
Michel collègue tout au long du 20e
siècle la France avait le meilleur
système de santé du monde mais depuis 30
ans si l'excellence est toujours là
notre système de santé publique
connaissant doute l'une des plus grandes
crises de notre son histoire c'est bien
simple trop de nos concitoyens ruraux en
particulier ne trouve plus de médecins
de ville et les médecins restants n'en
peuvent plus c'est tout le système de
santé qui doit donc se réinventer avec
l'investissement de tous à la mesure de
ses moyens et la responsabilité de
chacun le président de la République a
évoqué lors de ses vœux au personnel
soignants quelques pistes d'action dont
certaines méritent d'être précisées
parfois ce qui apparaît une bonne idée
peut s'avérer complexe un exemple celui
de 600 000 malades chroniques un malade
chronique peut avoir du diabète une
entorse au pied et où une dépression pas
de chance mesurez-vous mais où
devra-t-il s'adresser car le médecin de
ville et la personne à qui on parle de
tout vous me permettez en effet
d'adopter un point de vue celui du
patient qui cherche qui à la fois peur
et qui doit être aiguillé parce que ce
n'est pas son métier à ce titre le
préadressage est essentiel nous
souhaitons surdoster rapidement les
centres 15 et des 8 18 dans chaque
département nous demandons la mise en
œuvre rapide des plates formes de
services d'accès aux soins prévus pour
orienter convenablement les patients
dans une logique depuis
[Musique]
nous pensons utile de généraliser des
plateaux techniques avec des infirmiers
de pratique avancées permettant
d'effectuer de la bobologie quand cela
est utile ou de pré-adresser aux
urgences avec des examens déjà fait le
président de la République a évoqué un
dos d'un pour établir des permanences de
santé contre une consultation mieux
rémunérée des maisons médicales de garde
ouverte le week-end seraient pour nous
un objectif prioritaire les plateformes
savent pourraient être disposent déjà
disposés de créneaux de réservation de
rendez-vous des médecins de ville de
kiné ou des infirmiers nous souhaitons
un retour que les rendez-vous nous on
aurait soit sanction dans l'abus est
manifeste parce que ces créneaux sont
des trésors nous avons besoin d'une
réelle régulation publique décentralisée
et pluridisciplinaire
ou concentrer nos efforts pour le moyen
terme dans les territoires avec les
acteurs locaux et ceux dès le début de
la souveraineté supérieure de même que
nous avons constaté que les plus jeunes
médecins et infirmiers souhaitaient
pratiquer la médecine en collégialité il
faut je le crois proposer la même chose
à notre étudiants nous déplorons tous
ensemble que les jeunes médecins
s'installent ailleurs que dans nos
territoires ruraux ou sous-dotés mais
c'est oublier que la cassure
territoriale se fait dès le premier
stage d'internat nous proposons ainsi la
création de lycées médicaux ou d'options
médicales sur le modèle des lycées
agricoles nous croyons également
nécessaire de réintroduire un entretien
pour les inscriptions en école
d'infirmiers et facultés de médecine
pour éviter les abandons trop nombreux
mais aussi de permettre le redoublement
de première année pour éviter des fuites
à l'étranger nous proposons
l'agrandissement des ipsies et la
création de petits centres
universitaires médicaux décentralisée
dans des villes moyennes
un dossier à des logements ainsi les
étudiants en médecine insupportablement
sous-payés pourront découvrir avec leurs
amis de la réalité de nos territoires
dans une démarche contractualisée ils
n'auront plus à s'inquiéter de trouver
un toit ni chercher à revendre leur tour
de garde à des camarades plus riches
pour assurer leur subsistance les
collectivités locales ils sont prêtes
les Alpes-de-Haute-Provence ils sont
prêtes car nous savons que soignant en
devenir ou en place cette précieux ce
qui me permet d'en venir à mon dernier
point nos territoires sous dotés ont dû
investir dans des médecins interminèrent
hospitaliers parce que rien ne marchait
nous nous cautionnons pas ces pratiques
mais il faut cependant faire avec
l'existant le Conseil constitutionnel à
censurer une disposition du projet loi
de finance de la sécurité sociale
limitant le recours tandis que la loi
arrive prévoyait une restriction
d'emplois au cours de cette année le
flou profite déjà aux intérimaires qui
effectuent une liste d'établissement à
septembre c'est pratique et il est bien
évident que nous établissements publics
hospitaliers ne pourront pas s'aligner
madame la ministre comment nos hôpitaux
déjà exacts pourraient-ils tenir s'ils
sont désertés du jour au lendemain par
ses intérimaires nous pourrions-nous pas
créer dans ces cas précis des postes
fixes dans les structures concernées je
vous remercie de votre attention
madame la ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur sénateur
vous avez essayé vous m'avez posé
beaucoup de questions je vais y répondre
essayer de répondre à quelques-unes
concernant les 657000 de nos concitoyens
sous ALD c'est à dire qu'ils sont suivis
pour une pathologie chronique c'est
l'urgence il nous faut répondre
collectivement avec les médecins et
pouvoir et le cap a été fixé par le
président de la République avant la fin
de l'année que chaque passion sous elle
D et accès à un médecin traitant ce
travail il va être fait avec la Caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie où nous
allons très vite pouvoir appeler chaque
patient sous ALD et le mettre en contact
avec un médecin traitant nous sommes
dans la logique du gagnant-gagnant et
les médecins sont les premiers j'allais
dire concernés et ils veulent absolument
nous accompagner pour pouvoir répondre à
cette j'allais dire nécessité puisque
impatience vous LD qui décompense par
exemple sont diabète on va le retrouver
aux urgences donc il nous faut
travailler très vite sur ce sujet nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
ici la réforme j'allais dire où
l'évolution de du parcours de formation
de nos infirmiers et de nous infirmières
est nécessaire nous le savons un tout de
suite en première année de 30 %, 20 % à
la fin ça veut dire que 50 % de nos
jeunes qui rentrent dans le processus de
formation pour être infirmier ou
infirmière ne vont pas au bout ça veut
dire qu'il y a un problème le rapport
IGAS sur ce point est très clair et nous
allons très vite là aussi pouvoir faire
des propositions pour pour éviter éviter
cet écueil sur les rendez-vous non
honorés là aussi nous pourrons tous
apporter des mesures si nos concitoyens
aussi ne nous aident pas c'est à dire
les besoins de santé ne sont pas des
besoins de consommation comme un bien de
consommation comme un autre je prends un
rendez-vous je le respecte car si je ne
vais pas à ce rendez-vous c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui n'a pas pu être
prise en charge donc nous allons
travailler et faire des propositions sur
les rendez-vous non honorés
sur les packs avec les collectivités
souhaitées par le Président de la
République il est nécessaire et là aussi
mais nombreux déplacements montrent à
quel point l'investissement des
collectivités pour rendre le territoire
attractif pour accueillir soit des
jeunes internes soit des jeunes médecins
est intéressant je vais citer la maison
des internes à Morteau la maison des
internes à Morteau c'est un bel exemple
de ce travail de co-construction entre
les collectivités les ARS et les
soignants pour permettre aux jeunes de
venir découvrir le milieu rural ou
semi-ruramain et de pouvoir peut-être
vouloir s'y installer enfin sur
l'intérim vous savez que nous avons pris
la décision de la mettre en application
à partir du mois de mars cette loi est
votée il faut la mettre en indication
nous avons avec les ARS avec les
hôpitaux fait ce chemin les ARS sont
prévenus mais bien sûr il nous faut
trouver et fixer les personnels
oui monsieur le Président je vais
conclure je répondrai tout à l'heure
merci
la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente Catherine de roche pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues lors de ses vœux aux
acteurs du secteur le président de la
République a tenté de dresser un nouveau
cap pour la santé dans notre pays
ce cap est est nécessaire et attendu
après trois ans d'une pandémie qui a
épuisé les soignants et continue encore
de les mobiliser au quotidien il se
devait d'aller au-delà d'une sorte de
rediffusion de ma santé 2022 voir d'un
auto satisfait site presque gênant le
constat dressé par le Président de la
République est largement connu et
partagé les annonces en revanche
manquent de contenu et de crédibilité
concrète au service de la santé des
Françaises et des Français la médecine
de ville en Christ tiraillée entre des
besoins plus importants de la population
des déserts médicaux entre guillemets
toujours plus préoccupant et des
professionnels de santé qui en ont
insuffisants peine à dégager le temps
médical nécessaire
face à cela nous avons eu droit au
catalogue des annonces relatives au
système de santé des cinq dernières
années quelle signification concrète
pour la solidarité collective les
revalorisations différenciées la
valorisation de l'exercice coordonnée
certes ce n'est pas simplement une
question de moyens mais nous sommes au
milieu d'une négociation conventionnelle
particulièrement tendue d'un seul coup
le seuil de 20% des consultation ne
serait plus pertinent mais quel médecine
voulons-nous une médecine sans examen
clinique pratiqué dans des centres
d'appels éloignés des populations une
médecine qui pourrait devenir médecine à
deux vitesses vidant un peu plus encore
les territoires
la télémédecine a un outil
complémentaire mais ne doit pas être un
substitut ubérisé à une médecine de
qualité il faut embaucher davantage
d'assistant médicaux nous dit le
président soit mais pour ce qui est du
financement aucune précision bien sûr le
président de la République c'est aussi
prononcé sur la délégation d'acte
estimant qu'il fallait qu'elle soit je
cite simplifier généraliser et qu'il n'y
ait pas de conflit entre les professions
quels sont les choix concrets traduits
par cette formule civiline que veut dire
concrètement apporter une solution de
santé en incitant les acteurs de santé à
coopérer à coopérer entre eux quick par
exemple des infirmiers en pratique
avancés à peine cités par le président
au chapitre des solutions simples le
président de la République a annoncé
concernant les 6 millions de Français en
médecins traitant que les 600 000
malades chroniques qui n'en disposent
pas s'enverrai prochainement proposé un
par la Caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie et on se demande pourquoi cette
annonce n'est pas venue plus tôt mais
surtout se poser la question du nombre
de Français son médecin traitant une
chose se demandait le rôle de ce dernier
aujourd'hui dans le système de soins en
une autre or sur cette seconde question
nous n'avons pas vu de vision portée par
l'exécutif le médecin traitant doit être
la porte d'entrée mais pas le verrou de
notre système en disant cela certes on
ne fâche personne mais on ne résout
aucun problème quelle est la feuille de
route poursuivie par la multiplication
désordonnée des accès directs commencent
ces derniers sont-ils justifiés mais en
cohérence au-delà d'être la porte
d'entrée comment donner réellement
médecin traitant les moyens d'être le
pivot en Suède ou s'est rendu la
commission des affaires sociales le rôle
du médecin traitant n'est pas la
régulation laissez souvent infirmiers
mais bien le diagnostic médical et la
coordination des soins mais est-ce le
choix qui nous est annoncé du côté de
l'hôpital dans une crise tout aussi
profonde et durable malheureusement le
discours présidentiel n'était pas
beaucoup plus clair bien sûr l'annonce
choc relative à la tarification en
activité a fait beaucoup donc derrière
ce slogan d'une fin de la T2A le
président de la République n'a fait que
reprendre ce que la commission d'enquête
du Sénat appelée de ces violents
derniers un modèle de financement mixte
avec une part de dotation que l'on
appelle communément populationnel un
financement lié à la qualité et bien sûr
une part de me rendre assise sur
l'activité cette annonce ne suffira pas
à rassurer les professionnels de santé
car répétons le problème de la T2A n'est
pas de lier le financement l'activité
mais bien d'appliquer un tarif qui ne
couvre pas réellement les charges des
établissements et se tromper de problème
c'est apporter une mauvaise solution par
sur quoi on nous dit aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y aura pas de transition avec le
nouveau modèle sera voté dès le PLFSS
mais que de promesses quand nous voyons
que le gouvernement n'a même pas conduit
l'expérimentation d'un tel modèle
financement pourtant voter en LFSS pour
2021 et que les réformes du financement
des soins de suite ou la psychiatrie
jamais passer à la T2A ne sont toujours
pas effectives j'aimerais pour ma part
que le gouvernement nous fasse l'exégèse
du verbe préfiniel quand il programme on
doit sortir la tarification à l'activité
dès le prochain projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale tout
en annonçant plus loin une part de
rémunération à l'activité qui est
légitime et qui doit continuer surtout
en évoquant un changement de modèle de
financement le président Macron évite
précautionneusement le sujet de la
dépense et de sa régulation alors que
l'on nous annonce des revues de dépenses
et que la maîtrise de la dépense
publique est une nécessité quelle part
le gouvernement veut-il consacrer
réellement à l'hôpital car Madame le
Ministre ces nouveaux modèles de
financement n'est qu'une nouvelle règle
de partage du même du même gâteau et
le système actuel le premier engagement
qu'il faut prendre à l'égard de
l'hôpital c'est celui de l'humilité la
commission d'enquête sur l'hôpital avait
choisi de ne pas appeler à une nouvelle
loi santé comme elle avait revendiqué de
ne pas réengager des modifications de la
gouvernance estimant que le cadre issu
des réflexions du professeur Clarisse
laissez bien de la souplesse pour
revaloriser le service d'une part et
pour médicaliser la direction de l'autre
donc cessons d'annoncer des fausses
Révolutions des changements de paradigme
en trompe l'oeil le vrai besoin des
soignants aujourd'hui ce sont les
effectifs où en sont les recrutements
comment les hôpitaux sont-ils en
capacité de renouer avec l'attractivité
des postes des carrières et en capacité
de financer davantage de soignants au
lit des patients c'est cela la réalité
des prix madame les ministres et c'est
cela la réalité de la politique que vous
avez amenée la feuille donnée de route
donnée par le Président de la République
ne permet de déceler aucune ambition
concrète pour les soignants et le
système de qu'il porte et je le crâne à
n'en aucune politique structurée de la
part du gouvernement face à la crise que
nous connaissons vous l'avez compris mes
chers collègues cette année 2023
commence par des annonces qui n'en sont
pas pour des réalisations dont je crains
qu'elles n'en sont pas et je dirais des
mots toujours des mots les mêmes mots
rien que des mots je vous remercie et je
vous souhaite néanmoins madame la
ministre une excellente année 2023
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice alors je vais essayer par des
mots mais qui seront suivis d'acte de
vous convaincre tout d'abord sur les
assistants médicaux vous savez que
l'objectif qui est celui du gouvernement
c'est bien de passer de 4000 à 10000
assistants médicaux parce que un
assistant médical c'est 15 % de temps
médical gagné et donc 15 % que le
médecin généraliste pourra consacrer au
suivi d'un patient et prendre de
nouveaux patients sur le financement il
faut être clair le financement il est
annoncé c'est 36000 euros la première
année 27000 euros la deuxième année
21000 euros à partir de la troisième
année c'est à dire que le financement
combien est bien d'assurer après la
troisième année le médecin tête traitant
doit rester la pierre angulaire de notre
système de santé le président de la
République l'a clairement dit c'est une
volonté affichée et que nous assumons il
peut être de chef d'orchestre et ne sera
pas l'homme mort Crest je crois que le
Président de la République là aussi dit
donc vous l'avez forcément aussi bien
noté mais quand le président de la
République dit que ne peut pas être le
verrou ça veut dire que puisque nous
avons 6 milliards de nos concitoyens qui
n'ont pas de médecins traitant d'autres
professionnels pourraient être la porte
d'entrée pour amener ses patients vers
un médecin traitant sur la
téléconsultation vous savez que la crise
sanitaire a été j'allais dire un
accélérateur de l'usage de la
téléconsultation nous avons presque
gagné 15 ans sur le développement de la
téléconsultation néanmoins lorsque le
président de la République parle de ses
20% ça n'est pas déréguler le système
mais c'est prendre en compte que dans
certaines spécialités les 20% sont
bloquants je pense notamment à la
psychiatrie on voit bien que l'usage de
la téléconsultation pour la psychiatrie
les 20% sont limitants donc c'est bien
ça n'est pas déréguler le système mais
faire en sorte que on l'utilise au mieux
pour certaines spécialités mais aussi
j'allais dire comme et nous partageons
la même analyse c'est un complément et
dans certains territoires l'usage de la
téléconsultation peut-être
intéressante c'est bien l'objectif qui
est fixé le président de la République
n'a pas a commencé la suppression totale
de la T2A je vous le redis c'était dans
la feuille de route de 2018 nous le
savons je le redis qu'il était
impossible de réformer le financement de
l'hôpital avec la crise sanitaire que
nous avons traversé dès 2020 mais que
l'objet c'est bien de co-construire avec
les professionnels cette réforme de
l'hôpital de la tarification de
l'hôpital avec je le redis des enjeux de
prise en compte de la population des
prises en compte de qualité mais aussi
de pertinence des soins comment on évite
certaines dépenses monsieur le sénateur
Milon l'a évoqué tout à l'heure donc
tout ça est à co-construire sans sortir
complètement de la T2A puisque nous
savons que une part de la T2A pourra
être conservée et la réforme doit être
mise en place dès le PLPL FSS mais là
puisque vous avez été aussi bien bien
attentive vos discours nous allons
commencer le chantier dès le PLFSS 2024
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Daniel Chassin pour le groupe
Les Indépendants République et
territoire
monsieur le Président Madame lamis
messieurs collègues je voudrais tout
d'abord saluer le travail des soignants
que ce soit en ville en médico-social à
l'hôpital ils ont fait un travail
remarquons un travail remarquable dans
les conditions difficiles depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant le monde de
la santé fait face grave difficulté la
pandémie en a révélé et aggravé les
contraintes qui pèsent sur notre système
ceci malgré une augmentation importante
de l'ondables 4% cette année 57
milliards depuis 2017 nous sommes
maintenant un tournant nous ne pouvons
plus laisser notre système de santé se
dégrader davantage et avec vous Madame
la ministre nous devons trouver des
solutions pour remédier à la situation
à la croisée des nombreuses difficultés
que qu'on est que connaît notre système
se trouve les systèmes d'urgence leur
état d'engorgement est alarmant et mon
propos ira dans ce sens alors que l'État
doit pouvoir apporter des soins sur
l'ensemble du territoire des urgences
sont aujourd'hui devenus le dernier
rempart médical pour un nombre important
de nos concitoyens il est cependant
essentiel que ces services restent
focalisés sur les cas graves et pas être
embolisés par simplement des soins non
programmés qui n'ont pas trouvé de
médecin
pour qu'ils puissent accomplir au mieux
leur mission les services d'urgence
doivent être tout d'abord
préserver en amont par une régulation
efficace en Corrèze 10% de plus de
personnes sont allées aux urgences en
2022 après un double après un doublement
depuis 20 ans la régulation doit
permettre de distinguer ce qui relève de
l'urgence et ce qui n'en relève pas une
bonne régulation doit aussi
réorienter à cet égard il me semble
indispensable que les médecins de ville
qui auront à leur disposition des IPA
qui auront des assistants médicaux cela
pour libérer le temps de travail accepte
de réaliser davantage de soi non
programmés notamment ceux qui ont été
réorientés depuis les services d'accès
aux soins qui sont à côté du médecin
régulateur ses soins
pourrait être assuré effectivement dans
le cadre d'une CPTs communauté
professionnelle de territoire de la
santé avec des maisons de santé pouvant
être à tour de rôle pour prendre de
garde pour prendre en charge les soins
non programmés il convient également
de soulager les services d'urgence en
aval une fois la situation médicale du
patient stabilisé il faut le transférer
hors des urgences alors là le problème
arrive les fréquents que dans les autres
services hospitaliers devenus hyper
spécialisé refuse d'accueillir un
patient qui ne relève pas de leur
spécialité les services d'urgence n'ont
pourtant pas d'autres moyens
de conserver ces patients sans mettre en
péril l'exercice de leur mission il
faudrait mettre en place des services de
soins polyvalents en aval destiné à
accueillir des patients qui doivent être
hospitalisés pour cela Madame le
Ministre faut trouver les moyens de
rouvrir des lits beaucoup de lits ont
été fermés pour cause de manque de
personnel ces dernières années
pour les médecins la suppression du
numérique clausus bon j'en parle pas ça
sera seulement après 2030 mais
actuellement on peut faire des choses
pour les avoir pour créer des avantages
d'infirmières et d'aide-soignante
d'ailleurs ce besoin ne fera que croître
avec le temps
au fur et à mesure que la population
viendra plus dépendant notamment en
augmentant entre 2020 et 2030 la la
prévention sera nécessaire mais aussi la
prise en charge de nos aînés et
actuellement la prise en charge des
minuter dans les EHPAD et sa décourage
des soignants le plan grand âge doit se
mettre en place rapidement avec les 50
000 emplois annoncés par le ministre
monsieur comme comme
il faut aussi un plan massif de
formation la validation des acquis de
l'expérience semble une être une bonne
piste d'autre part depuis le pdfss ces
étudiants devront effectuer une
quatrième année d'internat auprès de
mettre de stage il y en a pas partout et
je suggère que les six derniers mois
puissent se réaliser auprès de médecins
référents pour irriguer tous les
territoires le médecin référent connaît
bien la patentielle pâtissière et tout à
fait apte à conseiller et orienter
d'autre part un médecin en 10e année qui
a passé
qui est en dixième année qui est Thésée
médecin senior doit être payé comme
remplaçant c'est à dire 10 consultations
par jour maximum donc le défi que nous
devons relever ce nombreux Madame le
Ministre ensemble le plus rapidement
possible résoudre les problèmes en amont
et en aval des urgences et embaucher
massivement des infirmières et des
aides-soignantes
cela pour effectivement prendre en
charge la le personne les personnes qui
arrivent aux urgences un aménagement de
la quatrième année est obligatoire pour
irriguer tout le territoire mais aussi
bien sûr comme ça a été dit aidez les
collectivités à embaucher des médecins
salariés et aussi la téléconsultation
peut aussi apporter quelques services
merci merci
madame la ministre
le président monsieur le sénateur vous
avez eu raison de le dire les défis qui
sont devant nous sont nombreux
effectivement ensemble que nous allons
trouver les solutions
au service de notre système de santé je
partage pleinement la nécessité de bien
assurer la gradation dans le recours aux
différents niveaux c'est par défaut que
les services d'urgence sont aujourd'hui
trop souvent la seule solution
identifiée par nos concitoyens le manque
de médecin en ville en est sans doute le
meilleur des exemples le déploiement du
service d'accès aux soins sera une vraie
solution pour être orientée en cas de
disponibilité de son médecin traitant
vers une solution de soins non
programmés à son à son état de santé
c'est clairement ce qui nous allons
faire puisque les services d'accès aux
soins à part après avoir été mis en
place cet été dans le cadre de la
mission d'urgence seront développés et
apportent une vraie réponse au
territoire en amont des urgences nous
sommes résolument engagés pour soutenir
les services de régulation avec un plan
massif pour attirer des candidats et
former des assistants de régulation
médicale mais aussi pour les médecins
régulateurs de nous avons déjà
revalorisé financièrement la mission
depuis l'été 2022 vous avez raison il
nous faut aussi agir en aval des
urgences pour fluidifier les parcours
pour cela nous avons réactivé les
cellules de gestion territoriale d'Hélie
qui ont fait leurs preuves durant la
crise sanitaire et permettent une vision
complète des capacités de l'ensemble des
établissements d'un territoire nous
avons aussi autorisé face aux tensions
induites par la triple épidémie des
mesures dérogatoires pour avoir
davantage de véhicules en charge de
réaliser des transports avec la
possibilité que l'assurance maladie
rembourse des trajets de taxi en sortie
des services d'urgence ou que des
équipages d'auxiliaires ambulanciers
assurent des transports ne nécessitant
pas de surveillance médicale la clé vous
le soulignez réside dans les ressources
humaines qu'il s'agisse de former de
nouveaux professionnels ou de convaincre
ceux qui ont quitté le système de
revenir ce sont tous les enjeux
d'attractivité et de prise en compte de
la pénibilité que nous sommes en train
de travailler actuellement et qui
doivent pouvoir produire des effets très
rapidement
merci je vais appeler Madame Mélanie
Vogel
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues nous débattant
aujourd'hui du thème la crise du système
de santé et je crains malheureusement
que cette question soit déjà obsolète
notre système de santé n'est plus en
crise une crise c'est soudain une crise
s'est brusque et momentanée et puis une
crise ça passe notre système de santé
n'est plus en crise
notre système de santé n'est même plus
au bord de l'effondrement notre système
de santé s'effondre sous nos yeux qui
aurait pu le prévoir et bien toute
personne s'est enseignée sur le sujet
aurait pu le prévoir car si notre
système de santé s'effondre c'est la
conséquence mécanique logique et
implacable de choix politiques de
mauvais choix politiques qui ont déjà
coûté des vies des vies parmi comme
toujours les plus précaires et qui
maltraite chaque jour des soignantes et
des soignants 36 des 38 infirmiers et
infirmières et soignants du service des
urgences de l'hôpital de Saint-Avold
sont en arrêt maladie 36 sur 38 résultat
il n'y a plus d'accueil la nuit à partir
de 19h 90% des effectifs des urgences de
l'hôpital de Pontoise en région
parisienne sont en arrêt maladie
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là je ne
peux plus entendre que c'est la faute du
covid c'est la faute de la grippe c'est
la faute des bronchiolites ou comme on
nous le rabâche tous les matins depuis
des mois c'est la faute des trois en
même temps un système de santé existe
pour éviter que les gens tombent malades
et pour les soigner quand ils le sont un
système de santé ne s'effondre pas à
cause des maladies comme un système
éducatif ne s'effondre pas à cause de
l'illettrisme comme un système
judiciaire ne s'effondre pas à cause des
crimes comme un système électoral ne
s'effondre pas à cause des élections le
système de santé est là parce que la
maladie existe parce que la prévention
est nécessaire et parce que la guérison
est possible c'est son objet le sens
même de son existence et s'il s'effondre
parce que les gens ne tombent malades
c'est qu'il s'effondre de lui-même et
s'il s'effondre de lui-même c'est parce
qu'il a été sous-financé au point qui ne
puisse simplement plus tenir je ne peux
pas entendre non plus que c'est la faute
des 35 heures quelle restaurant mépris à
l'encontre de celles et ceux qui à bout
de souffle s'épuisent chaque jour et
chaque nuit et qui persiste à le faire
malgré tout pour faire la mission qu'ils
ont accepté soignés si pour soigner il
faut soi-même être malade et épuisé si
pour guérir les autres il faut se tuer à
la tâche si notre système de santé doit
reposer sur des personnes condamnées à
en avoir besoin qu'elle leur elles sont
pas en bonne santé tout ça n'a plus
aucun sens alors non la responsabilité
de l'effondrement dans notre système de
santé publique ce ne sont ni les
maladies ni les 35 heures la
responsabilité elle encombe à celles et
ceux qui ont organisé le
désinvestissement de l'hôpital public le
forfait passant urgence les salaires de
misère des conditions de travail
indignes la tarification à l'acte les
fermetures de lit les fermetures de
services et des déserts médicaux notre
système de santé il subit l'enchaînement
depuis plusieurs décennies de décisions
politiques à courte vue domin par une
idéologie mortifère qui consiste à
considérer que les services publics
doivent coûter le moins cher possible et
que la santé et de ne pas reconnaître
que la santé est un bien commun et que
le service public qui s'en occupe doit
et cela fait tellement d'années qu'on le
dit être organisé uniquement en fonction
des besoins mais il y a sans doute plus
grave encore c'est que Pierre arrive
permettez-moi de vous lire quelques
phrases selon un rapport de l'OMS de
2016 23% des décès dans le monde sont
directement liées au fait d'avoir vécu
ou travailler dans un environnement
insalubre et ce sont les plus
défavorisés qui supportent la plus forte
charge de morbidité liée à
l'environnement le changement climatique
et l'appauvrissement de la biodiversité
provoqueront des chocs écologiques de
forte amplitude sur notre économie et la
société dont la pandémie actuelle il
date un peu le texte d'origine zone
nautique n'est qu'une des premières
manifestations notre protection sociale
n'est pas suffisamment résiliente face
aux risques environnementaux et
ne s'est pas doté des outils prospectifs
pour faire face à la survenance plus
fréquente et plus aiguë d'événements
climatiques et de crises imprévues dont
les effets sur les finances publiques
seront lourdes conséquences la pandémie
la montrer avec force les chocs futures
risquent d'être encore plus violents il
est donc urgent de changer de paradigme
avec des politiques publiques dans
l'impact environnemental est prise en
compte dès la conception et un
développement et un développant une
culture de prévention d'adaptation et de
résilience de notre système de
protection sociale
ces quelques lignes c'est pas moi qui
les ai écrites enfin pas directement
elles viennent du rapport sénatorial
adopté par notre chambre sur la sécurité
sociale écologique dont j'avais
l'honneur d'être la rapportrice qui peut
prévoir l'impasse vers laquelle nous
font son et bien ici tout le monde le
seul truc c'est que tout le monde n'est
pas ici au pouvoir pour les éviter
merci la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Luc
Fichet pour le groupe socialiste ah oui
madame la ministre excusez-moi
mettre dans le bain un peu
allez-y madame la Présidente
madame la sénatrice
voilà tout d'abord je vais le redire
c'est bien parce que pas de traversons
pas une crise mais que c'est bien
l'enjeu de la réforme structurel de
notre système de santé qu'il nous faut
accomplir que nous parlons de
refondation comme tout activité mène le
système de santé bien sûr sensible aux
enjeux climatiques le gouvernement fait
de la santé environnementale une de ses
priorités dans la politique de santé
j'ai dans ma feuille de route la santé
environnementale j'étais ce matin aux
travaux du Haut Conseil de la santé
publique sur lequel nous avons pu
commencer à tracer quelques briques d'un
projet de santé environnementale dont
j'aurai sans doute dans les semaines à
venir l'occasion de venir vous parler la
France fait partie des États européens
les plus engagés en matière de santé
environnementale elle élabore tous les 5
ans un plan national santé environnement
décliné en région inscrit dans le Code
de la santé publique ces plans
successifs ont permis des avancées
notables pour réduire l'impact de
l'environnement sur la santé une
meilleure prise en compte de la Santé
Environnement à toutes les échelles du
territoire et le développement de
programmes de recherche St le quatrième
plan a été lancé en 2021 il comporte
plusieurs axes pour réduire les
expositions environnementales affectant
la santé humaine ou mieux connaître les
expositions et les effets de
l'environnement sur la santé des
populations et des écosystèmes de même
nous intégrons les impacts
environnementaux des activités de santé
la question de l'évacuation des déchets
d'activités de soins à risques
infectieux sans atteinte dans
l'environnement ou en développant les
possibilités de recyclage font ainsi
l'objet de travaux avec l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé ces enjeux
concernent beaucoup de beaucoup de
ministères et soyez convaincus que le
gouvernement fait mais tout en oeuvre
pour que ce dossier soit traité de façon
interministérielle et systématiquement
je suis au côté de Christophe Béchu et
de Bérengère Couillard lorsqu'il s'agit
de parler de problèmes d'air ou de
problèmes d'eau parce que la santé la
santé environnementale c'est quelque
chose dont nous devons nous préoccuper
et c'est ce que nous mettons en oeuvre
et puis prévenir c'est guérir donc la
prévention est aussi un enjeu majeur de
la politique que nous de que nous avons
bien l'intention le mener ni un ministre
de la santé et de la prévention et dans
le cadre du PLFSS nous avons déjà pris
des mesures en 60 merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est donc à Monsieur
Jean-Luc fiché pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain pour 4 minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tous les secteurs de
la santé dans notre pays traversent une
crise profonde médecine de ville hôpital
profession paramédicale tous les acteurs
de santé font état de leur épuisement et
de leur découragement la santé est un
bien commun chaque citoyen devrait
pouvoir se faire soigner d'une manière
optimale ce qui est loin d'être le cas
depuis de nombreuses années la crise
actuelle renforce ma conviction profonde
de la nécessité absolue de la création
d'un nouveau service public de la santé
fort rappelons une évidence le service
public et le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas les réactions des différents
acteurs de la santé à l'intervention
présidentielle de vendredi dernier sont
majoritairement marqués par un sentiment
de déception
le président Macron
le plus en Macron est fidèle à sa ligne
politique avec par exemple la remise en
cause des 35 heures à l'hôpital vieille
lune de la droite la réponse au malaise
actuel de l'hôpital serait de faire
travailler plus les personnels
hospitaliers sans que ceci gagne plus
rappelons que dans le cas de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 2023
a été votée par la majorité
présidentielle la possibilité pour les
médecins les infirmières de travailler
jusqu'à 72 ans quel cynisme il est
urgent de dégager de vraies solutions
pour répondre à la pénibilité des
métiers beaucoup d'infirmières par
exemple abandonne moins de 5 ans après
leur diplôme
certaines solutions
préconisées peuvent sembler aller dans
le bon sens comme la remise en cause de
la tarification à l'activité à l'hôpital
la T2A mais attention aux modalités
d'application
et pouvez-vous nous préciser ce que sont
les objectifs de santé à l'échelle d'un
territoire évoqué par le président le
président aussi évoqué des conseils
d'administration des hôpitaux qui
semblent-ils se substitueraient au
conseil de surveillance actuelle peut-on
être éclairé sur ce point il vous
appartiendra madame la ministre de
mettre en application des annonces
présidentielles mais force de constater
que vous apparaissez affaibli par la
nécessité éprouvée par le Président de
la République de monter en première
ligne
la réorganisation de la médecine de
ville à peu près abordée du vilain peu
été abordé alors que c'est le cœur du
problème les dispositifs d'incitation
échoué même l'ancienne ministre de la
Santé Roselyne Bachelot le dit
initiative d'ailleurs qui dispositif qui
était à son initiative d'ailleurs pas de
contraintes non plus pour les gardes des
médecins libéraux obligations de garde
qui permettrait pourtant de décharger
les urgences hospitalières des petites
urgences aucune réflexion sur les
conditions d'exercice pourtant difficile
des internes en médecine hospitalière
rappelons que 30% de nos concitoyens
vivent dans un désert médical 6 millions
de Français n'ont pas de médecins
traitant dont 600 miles d'entre eux
pourtant en affection de longue durée et
les mesures annoncées vendredi dernier
sur ce point précis ne rassure pas
la délégation de soins est donc la
possibilité de prescrire au paramédicaux
est une orientation intéressante mais
dangereuse si elle n'apporte pas
l'adhésion des professionnels de santé
et si elle n'est pas présentée dans le
cadre d'un projet global le président de
la République semble avoir totalement
renoncé volontarisme politique dans le
domaine de la santé pas d'annonce sur un
moteur sur les fermetures de lit
incertitude sur les moyens pas d'annonce
sur les déserts médicaux la santé a
besoin d'un plan global cohérent loin
des annonces à l'emporte-pièce c'est
pourquoi nous sénateur socialiste
écologiste et républicains nous sommes
favorables à une véritable plan massive
d'investissement dans le domaine de la
santé en conclusion de mon intervention
je veux insister son importance
d'associer l'ensemble des parlementaires
des sénateurs à la construction d'un
projet global de santé pour notre pays
seul à même de garantir le droit à la
santé
je voudrais aussi dans le cadet
infections
[Musique]
la sentier est un bien commun et c'est
bien parce que tous les acteurs et tous
les secteurs
ne vont pas bien qu'il nous faut je le
redis refonder l'ensemble de notre
système de santé c'est-à-dire à la fois
l'hôpital et à la fois la ville le
Président de la République n'a pas remis
en cause les 35 heures il a simplement
dit qu'il fallait donner plus de
souplesse et plus d'autonomie pour
permettre au système hospitalier pour
permettre à l'échelle d'un service
d'organiser les emplois du temps des
personnels soignants afin de
reparticiper et de reprendre en compte
cette qualité au travail de permettre de
leur redonner du sens et de permettre
aux personnels soignants peut-être de
rester à l'échelle de ce service et de
ne pas je l'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure
comme c'est le cas dans trop de services
actuellement allés de services en
service mais de rester dans le service
qu'elles ont choisi la réforme de la T2A
qui doit être programmé dans le cadre du
prochain pdfss la réflexion sera lancée
avec des objectifs de santé publique
qu'il nous faut qu'on construire et
qu'il nous faut qu'on construit aussi à
l'échelle des territoires je le redis
les objectifs de santé publique ne
peuvent pas être
identiques dans tous les territoires ça
n'est pas possible même si nous devons
assurer un socle et enfin en ce qui
concerne les médecins la convention
médicale est en cours les discussions
ont lieu elles auront lieu jusqu'au mois
de mars nous sont avec les médecins
généralistes dont je répète que nous
souhaitons que la médecine de ville
s'inscrivent dans une logique de
gagnant-gagnant que le médecin
généraliste doit rester traitant doit
rester la pierre angulaire de notre
système de santé c'est négociations sont
en cours 650 000 personnes sous elles
des 100 médecins traitant c'est un
objectif ambitieux nous arriverons avec
les médecins à répondre à ses besoins de
pour nos concitoyens et enfin en ce qui
concerne la délégation de tâches elles
ne se fera pas contre les professionnels
mais elle se co-construira bien avec les
professionnels et toutes les
professionnels c'est l'enjeu du Clio et
de la volonté partagée par tous les
ordres qui a été signé c'est ce que nous
allons mettre en œuvre avec les
professionnels de santé
monsieur
voyez monsieur fichier il y a cette
réplique c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
chacun respecte son 6 minutes la
Présidente je vais en profiter pour
conclure terminé mon propos puisque ce
que je voulais en conclusion c'est dit
aussi qu'il était temps dans la
réflexion qui était la nôtre de
peut-être mettre un arrêt à la gestion
privée lucrative des établissements de
santé à l'instar de ce qui se passe dans
les maisons de retraite et à l'éclairage
de ce qu'on a vécu avec ORPEA je pense
que c'est un système de gestion privé
lucratif qu'il faut réinterroger pour
mieux s'orienter vers le public et le
privé non lucratif je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Nadia sur
le goût pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 4 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues notre système de
santé traverse une crise grave profonde
inédite généralisée dont les victimes
sont tout autant les soignants que les
patients chacun d'eux ce sont lésé
oubliés désespérés le principe est
mathématique d'un côté une demande de
soin de l'autre une offre de soins
l'unité de mesurer le temps horaire il
faut réussir très vite à remettre un
signe égal entre les deux membres de
cette équation du côté de la demande de
soins il faut un travail de fond sur la
prévention d'une part et la bonne
orientation des patients d'autre part
éviter que ce volume ne soit gonflé par
tout ce qui est évitable et par les
actes redondants tout particulièrement
la prévention est une mesure qui relève
du temps long l'efficacité du parcours
de soins dans le temps plus court mais
très perturbé par la pénurie généralisée
de soignants associer une forme de
panique des patients qui leur fait
rechercher n'importe quelle solution en
cas de besoin du côté de l'offre de
soins le volume est largement
insuffisant toute profession de santé
confondues concernant l'offre de temps
médical il faut des mesures urgentes et
parfois de simples bon sens qui nous
remontent du terrain que vous connaissez
pourtant mais qui n'arrive pas à être
opérationnel par exemple les dossiers de
médecins étrangers européens ou non aux
équivalences reconnues en France doivent
être traités en urgence par les services
du conseil de leur national ils sont des
milliers en souffrance en attente
parfois depuis des mois d'une date de
réunion de commission on nous sollicite
tous les jours pour des dossiers de
cette nature incroyable qu'on ne puisse
pas faire mieux renforcer les services
si le faux madame la ministre pour
reprendre mon équation à multiples
inconnus je ne pense pas que le temps
médical soit toujours optimisé des
délégations de tâches de soins et les
médecines dans certains cas allégement
des tâches administratives il faut que
les médecins puissent se concentrer sur
leur principal plus-values c'est-à-dire
le diagnostic et cesse de perdre la
moindre minute en transport ou à remplir
des papiers par exemple
le nombre de ces derniers conditionne
bien évidemment le volume de temps
médical offert si les nouveaux
praticiens pour de multiples raisons
produisent globalement en deux fois
moins de temps médical que ceux des
générations précédentes et bien il
faudrait théoriquement en former deux
fois plus même en modulant avec les
autres leviers force et de constater
qu'avec 12000 médecins formés par an au
lieu de 20000 la situation ne fera en
fait qu'empirer nos facs de médecine nos
professeurs de médecine même avec les
cours en distanciels ont-ils atteint un
maximum capacitaires quand on sait que
chaque année désormais des professeurs
de médecine démissionnent de leur chair
faute de moyens pour mener leurs travaux
on comprend qu'il faut redonner de
l'attractivité à ces carrières
essentielles car voir nos étudiants à
partir en Roumanie ont en Espagne pour
se former c'est un élitisme
insupportable et un graphe constat
d'échec d'une façon plus générale
l'attractivité des carrières est un
sujet d'une brûlante actualité les
médecins généralistes ne réclament pas
qu'une augmentation de leurs actes
j'entends surtout qu'il demande le
dialogue la reconnaissance et les moyens
d'attirer partout sur le territoire de
jeunes praticiens passionnés je me
demande comment se sentent les étudiants
en fin de cursus avant de faire le grand
saut dans la marmite bouillonnante du
système de santé français ce ne sont pas
des primes qu'il faut leur donner mais
des assurances nous manquons de 60 000
infirmiers et 120 000 diplômés
n'exercent pas en France peut-on renouer
le dialogue avec ces derniers c'est plus
immédiat que d'en former de nouveau et
comment éviter que nos futurs diplômés
ne jettent l'éponge au bout de quelques
années ce gâchis de formation est
dramatique écoute terriblement cher
l'attractivité le G je l'ai dit n'est
pas que financière nos auditions nous
laissent entendre qu'il s'agit aussi à
l'hôpital de gouvernance de lourdeurs
administratives à cet égard le modèle de
l'hôpital de Valenciennes où les
soignants semblent s'épanouir et dont le
budget est excédentaire peut-il être une
source d'inspiration j'ai évoqué la
situation des médecins des infirmiers
mais que dire des aides soignants sage
femme formée en nombre dramatiquement
insuffisant des dentistes qui sont
toujours en dessous des radars des kinés
qui doivent bénéficier de certaines
chers collègues merci voilà merci
beaucoup
madame la ministre
[Musique]
répétitif plus simple qui peuvent être
délégués à d'autres professionnels
paramédicaux la délégation tact doit
être simplifiée généralisée et
s'inscrire dans l'univers dans l'une
dans une logique d'exercices coordonnées
ou de réseau pour inciter chacun à
coopérer sur les padules nous avons voté
dans le cadre du pdfss la date du 30
avril de dominante 3 pour gérer la
partie du stock cet objectif sera tenu
nous avions une réunion pas plus tard
que tout à l'heure avec l'Ordre des
médecins qui prend l'engagement de nous
accompagner avec le CNG pour tenir ce
cap de avril 2023 pour téter le stock et
de travailler dans le cadre de pugel
immigration sur la nouvelle parcours de
du flux dont nous avons parlé récemment
s'agissant de mon Espace Santé 65
millions de nos Français ont aujourd'hui
un espace ouvert et moins de 2% des
citoyens se sont opposés à sa création
plus de 5 millions de documents sont
versés chaque mois dans les espaces
santé c'est un outil au service de la
coopération entre le professionnel de
santé ainsi qu'aux bénéfice de français
pour pouvoir s'approprier pleine leur
dossier médical et vous avez raison
renouer avec tous les professionnels qui
exercent plus c'est aussi un moyen de
plus rapidement les faire revenir dans
le système de santé et répondre à ce
manque de professionnels qui est criant
et qui je le répète c'est pas un manque
de moyens c'est bien professionnel merci
même sur le couple
j'ai bien parlé d'une équation ou en
parlant de temps médical et pas en
nombre de professionnels de santé si
bien que même si on forme dix mille
praticiens 10% de praticiens de médecins
en plus en fait il donne quand même
beaucoup moins de temps médical qu'avant
donc s'il donne deux fois moins de temps
médical c'est pas 10% de plus qu'il faut
c'est deux fois plus donc l'équation
elle est mauvaise donc le fait d'avoir
supprimé le numéro ce clausus clausus ça
ça règle pas du tout le problème on en
forme toujours pas assez même après
suppression du numerus clausus 10% de
plus c'est totalement insuffisant et ça
va être de pire en pire voilà merci
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
Corinne Imbert pour le groupe les
républicains pour 7 minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous voilà donc
aujourd'hui réunis pour un débat
d'actualité intitulé la crise du système
de santé malheureusement le terme
d'actualité est un euphémisme quand une
situation dure et se dégrade de jour en
jour de moins en moins et d'année en
année on parle alors de routine
quotidienne si délétère soit-elle le
sujet est vaste et ces quelques minutes
ne seraient d'être suffisantes pour
balayer les multiples causes qui ont
conduit à la situation actuelle la
pandémie a évidemment aggravé la
situation avec l'épuisement des
professionnels de santé à l'hôpital
comme en ville mais elle a surtout été
révélatrice de la perte de notre
souveraineté sanitaire
la crise du système est d'abord le fruit
de plusieurs années de politique
hasardeuse en matière de santé comment
ne pas rappeler les coups de rabot subit
par l'hôpital et par le secteur du
médicament et du dispositif médical dans
une logique de la recherche d'une
maîtrise des dépenses de santé et de la
réduction du déficit de la Sécurité
sociale comment en est-on arrivé là
les 35 heures non compensé appliqués à
l'hôpital alors que ce dernier prend en
charge des patients 24 heures sur 24 si
un jour sur 7 qu'on le veuille ou non
elles l'ont désorganisé des efforts du
coup sans compter demander aux internes
au titre de leur formation et dans la
contribution est au combien important
dans le fonctionnement du coût de
l'hôpital il en a résulté une formation
pendant des années très hospital au
centre année pendant lesquels la
médecine générale a été aussi
dévalorisée le souci du déficit de la
Sécurité sociale qui est d'abord le
souci d'une juste dépense de l'argent
public mais qui depuis des années a vu
Bercy prendre le pas sur l'avenue
Duquesne une exception il faut le
reconnaître la pandémie qui a conduit
pour répondre à cette crise sanitaire à
un déficit historique de la sécurité
sociale
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie pour 2023 rejeté
dans cette hémicycle en novembre dernier
illustre l'incohérence entre d'un côté
des moyens financiers importants 250
milliards d'euros et d'un autre côté des
missions d'intérêt général par exemple
mal identifié et le financement de
l'hôpital pour laquelle il n'y a pas de
débat faute d'information
le 15 décembre dernier j'allaise
également le gouvernement lors des
traditionnels question d'actualité sur
le thème de la souveraineté sanitaire
entre autres le sujet des ruptures de
stock de médicaments et de vaccins qui
avaient déjà fait l'objet en 2018 donc
avant la pandémie d'une mission
d'information sénatoriale alors même que
le monde traverse une tempête
diplomatique inédite depuis la fin de la
guerre froide il semble fondamental de
prendre un bras le corps cette question
de la souveraineté sanitaire tient
d'ailleurs à saluer l'initiative de nos
collègues du groupe CSE visant à créer
une commission d'enquête sur les
ruptures de stock et ainsi poursuivre
les travaux sur ce sujet à titre
personnel je n'ai jamais vu une
citadelle situation en 40 ans d'exercice
professionnel
je suis sûr que vous êtes dans la même
situation madame la ministre enfin la
question de la souveraineté du
médicament est intimement liée aussi à
son prix qu'on le veuille ou non dans un
marché concurrentiel certains
laboratoires préfèrent se tourner alors
que la demande est mondiale vers des
pays où les prix sont plus avantageux
ceci a des conséquences directes
une demande mondiale qui augmente mais
également des conséquences sur la
capacité d'innovation dans le domaine de
la recherche
ce pose ainsi la question par exemple de
l'efficience dans certains cas de la
clause de sauvegarde enfin sur la
question de la fixation du prix du
médicament je rappelle qu'un amendement
avait été voté à l'initiative de notre
collègue en école Savary afin
d'encourager les entreprises du
médicament qui relocaliserait leur site
de production en Europe malheureusement
le gouvernement n'a pas écouté la
sagesse du Sénat
comment ne pas évoquer lors de ce débat
la question de la formation en internat
de médecine générale je rappellerai une
nouvelle fois c'est pas la première fois
que je le rappelle mais qu'il y a un
amendement avait été voté à la case
unanimité du Sénat lors de la loi de
santé de 2019 fin transformer la
dernière année de 3e si de métier
général en une année de
professionnalisation dans les
territoires sous dotés à l'issue de la
commission mixparitaire nous avions
trouvé un accord sur un semestre décret
n'est jamais paru et depuis lors du
dernier pdfss le gouvernement a repris
l'idée d'une quatrième année donc l'idée
de la proposition du président Bruno
Retailleau votez en octobre dernier
d'une quatrième année de
professionnalisation pour les internes
en médecine générale dans le cadre de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 de constat amer sur ce
sujet premièrement que de temps perdu
depuis la loi 2019 cette mesure aurait
pu rentrer en application je le rappelle
depuis le 1er novembre 2021
deuxièmement vous avez dénaturé cette
mesure en permettant que cette quatrième
année puisse en partie être réalisée à
l'hôpital alors que l'esprit initial
était de renforcer une médecine de ville
aux abois
pour rester sur le sujet majeur de
l'accès aux soins je rappellerai
l'importance qu'occupe et que doit
continuer d'occuper la médecine générale
le peu de temps que le Président de la
République a consacré dans son discours
de vœux à la médecine de ville interroge
voire est un peu choquant l'hôpital ira
mieux si la médecine de ville va mieux
nous sommes face à un système de santé
au bord de la rupture cette phrase n'est
pas de moi même si parfois à la fin
d'une journée je peux le penser
c'est le cri d'alarme du collège de la
Haute Autorité de Santé en avril 2022 le
collège de la HAS en effet publié une
lettre ouverte je cite à tous ceux qui
œuvrent pour la qualité des soins et des
accompagnements tout y était pénurie des
personnels soignants et médicaux déserts
médicaux mauvaise qualité des soins
accès aux soins le collège propose en
bien sûr en face de ce cri d'alarme
proposant des mesures à mettre en place
en urgence madame la ministre avez-vous
pris connaissance de cet appel de la HAS
et qu'en avez-vous fait si ce jugement
est sévère et nous attriste tous c'est
aussi par endroits une triste réalité
les professionnels de santé l'ensemble
des soignants sont épuisés sont sous
l'eau et je m'inquiète du jour où la
digue pourrait sauter car je vous le
rappelle madame la ministre un
effondrement de notre système de santé
aurait des conséquences sur l'ensemble
de la société et menacerait directement
l'équilibre de ce pays je tiens à saluer
tous ceux qui tiennent bon et qui
continuent avec conscience
professionnelle et abnégation de prendre
en charge chaque jour des patients je
tiens également à rappeler formidable
implication des élus locaux qui se
battent sans relâche afin de faciliter
l'installation de professionnels de
santé dans leur commune c'est un
véritable crit désespoir de la part des
élus et des patients que nous entendons
régulièrement dans nos départements
respectifs la crise de notre système de
santé est évidemment majeure à l'hôpital
et en médecine de ville nombreuses sont
les professionnels de santé prêt
pourtant à vouloir sauver ce système
dans l'intérêt des patients grâce aussi
à des progrès technologiques et à des
innovations thérapeutiques majeures mais
cette crise de notre système de santé
impacte déjà le secteur médico-social et
tous les acteurs qui interviennent dans
la prise en charge des personnes âgées
et des personnes handicapées à domicile
ne l'oublions pas que dire du Ségur dans
l'intention initiale était bonne mais
qui engendrait des oubliés et des
oubliés des oubliés parler de
l'attractivité des métiers ne suffit pas
il faut effectivement fidéliser ceux qui
sont en poste enfin si vous pouvez
compter sur les maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnel et les professionnels
de santé qui les composent ayez le
courage de reconnaître que les
communautés professionnel
territorial de santé ne sont pas la
solution merci chers collègues
[Rires]
je finirai après
madame la sénatrice
je vais essayer de répondre vous avez
posé beaucoup de questions au moins sur
la partie concernant la pénurie des
médicaments donc annoncé par le
président de la République en 2021 le
volet santé du plan France 2030 prévoit
un ensemble de mesures législatives et
réglementaires ainsi que 7,5 milliards
d'euros pour faire de la France la
nation la plus innovante et souveraine
en santé d'Europe il s'agit notamment de
faire de la France un leader en matière
de produits de santé innovant et de
renforcer la tractivité la France c'est
un défi majeur que nous avons largement
abordé pendant la crise sanitaire et
pour lequel nous agissons notre objectif
c'est de réinstaller en France et plus
largement en Europe ces industries
essentielles de production de
médicaments des projets de
relocalisation très concret émergent
progressivement et permettront à terme
de limiter notre dépendance vous le
savez l'usine de paracétamol avec le
projet séquence l'usine de masque est de
gants en nitrile l'usine de production
de médicaments dérivés du sang à partir
du plan plasma
à Arras en 2023 l'objectif national des
dépenses d'assurance maladie était fixée
à 244 milliards d'euros soit une
croissance de 3,5%
or dépense covid il est donc difficile
de parler de coudre à beau et je vous le
répète le budget santé a augmenté de 20%
entre 2017 et 2023 par ailleurs aucune
économie n'est envisagée sur les
hôpitaux s'agissant de la quatrième
année du Diplôme d'Études spécialisée de
médecine générale il ne s'agit pas de
réaliser un stade en jau-soudance cette
réforme a pour objectif de doter la
spécialité de médecine générale d'une
phase de consolidation c'est un apport
pédagogique qui vise à permettre au
docteur junior d'acquérir de l'autonomie
dans le cadre protecteur de la
supervision pour pouvoir s'installer
rapidement ensuite à la sortie des
études la maquette de formation du
troisième cycle des études de médecine
générale et d'ailleurs en cours de
révision dans le cadre de cette réforme
la médecine générale et l'hôpital
doivent être réformés c'est l'objet de
la reformation de la refondation et nous
sommes d'accord sur ce sujet merci
Madame Humbert
merci madame le Président merci madame
la ministre vous terminez vos propos en
parlant de refondation du coup je vais
rebondir président de la République dans
son dans ses vœux à parler d'un Conseil
national de la refondation locale table
aminis sofaite atteint de réunionites
aiguë les professionnels de santé n'ont
pas de temps à perdre je disais à la fin
mes propos que vous savez pouvoir
compter sur les maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelles et sur les
professionnels de santé qui les
composent
sur les communautés professionnelles
territoire territoriales de santé elles
ne sont pas la solution certaines
fonctionnent bien mais elles ne sont pas
la solution oui mais le ministère via
les URPS veulent qu'elle couvre tout le
territoire national pourquoi dans le
département que je connais le mieux
c'est là où il y a le plus de problèmes
qui en a pas parce que nous n'avons pas
de temps à perdre voilà les
professionnels de santé peuvent être de
très très bonnes volonté si des médecins
changent s'ils des patients ont changé
vous allez pouvoir compter sur eux pour
s'organiser en proximité et les laisser
faire et aller pas l'essentiel merci
beaucoup alors je vais donner la parole
à Madame Agnès Firmin le Baudot ministre
donc délégué chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
pour conclure ce débat pour 5 minutes
madame la présidence mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs la
crise du système de santé vous avez
choisi d'y consacrer l'un de vos
premiers débats pour cette année 23 qui
s'ouvre et je partage avec vous cette
priorité qui est celle de s'attaquer aux
difficultés structurelles qui parcourent
notre système de santé comme je partage
avec vous ce sens de l'urgence que
soustant explicitement la notion de
crise que vous avez choisi de développer
en effet si nous souhaitons aujourd'hui
tout juste de la violente tempête
épidémique de la covid 19 dont les
vagues successives ont ébranlé notre
système de santé notre santé n'en est
pas moins en crise et vos nombreuses
questions et interventions le démontre
car oui la baisse inexorable de la
ressource médicale qui est la
conséquence de choix politiques d'un
autre temps le vieillissement de notre
population la mutation des modes de vie
et des aspirations des professionnels de
santé la perte de sens de ces beaux
métiers du soin ce sont là les
déterminants d'une crise systémique dans
un monde qui change ce constat de crise
ce diagnostic il a déjà été maintes fois
été posé le président de la République a
eu l'occasion de le rappeler lors de ses
vœux aux acteurs de la santé vendredi
dernier une fois cela dit est répété il
nous faut désormais être à la hauteur
dans ce qui constitue aujourd'hui un
moment charnière nous devons bâtir le
président de la République a tracé un
cap clair le 6 janvier dernier dans son
allocution à l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes avec des jalons de mise
en oeuvre pour avancer ensemble dans ce
chantier collectif nous avons un horizon
et les objectifs de trop combat reste
celui de la lutte contre toutes les
inégalités en matière de santé qu'elle
soit sociale géographique où il y a des
violnérabilités particulières comme le
handicap ou le grand âge
un chiffre pour moi est le symbole de
cette crise de l'accès aux soins
657000 de nos concitoyens atteint de
maladies chroniques vous l'avez évoqué
plusieurs fois non pas accès à un
médecin traitant ou un équipe soignante
cette réalité il faut la regarder en
face sans pour autant qu'elle en
devienne moins intolérable j'ai pu
levoquer une bonne politique et celle
qui se fait rencontrer le temps bref des
crises avec le temps long des grands
changements structurels nous avons
transformé le numerus clossus en numéro
sapertus et corriger une erreur
historique mais les bénéfices de cette
réforme ne seront visibles que dans une
décennie aussi notre objectif et notre
défi c'est de mobiliser tous les leviers
nous permettant de gagner du temps
médical pour ne soignants au service des
patients ce temps nous le dégagerons en
délaissant les médecins de toutes les
tâches notamment administratives qui
ronge sur leurs emplois du temps déjà
largement surchargé
ce temps nous le partageons mieux entre
les différents maillons de la chaîne de
soins dans des organisations coordonnées
où chacun à sa place pourra être le plus
efficace et le plus utile
concrètement cela passe d'une part par
l'accélération des recrutements
d'assistants médicaux dont nous voulons
porter le nombre de 4000 à 10000 d'ici
l'an prochain cela passe par un effort
inédit sur les formations paramédicales
avec notamment l'augmentation de 20% des
places en institut de soins infirmiers
et ces nouveaux paramédicaux nous leur
donnerons des perspectives d'évolution
de carrière et de nouvelles compétences
grâce à toutes les mesures et
expérimentations concernant la pratique
avancée l'accès direct et les
délégations de compétences les efforts
de chacun nous nous assurons que leur
charge est plus Itech équitablement
réparties
hospitalier et libéraux clinique et
hôpitaux doivent participer avec la même
intensité à la permanence des soins et
seront rémunérés en conséquence pour la
médecine de ville comme pour notre
hôpital nous oserons prendre à bras le
corps des dossiers touchants au cœur de
son organisation en accompagnement ses
transferts
avec en particulier une direction
hospitalière rénovée pour mieux
équilibrer les décisions une bascule de
la rémunération à l'activité vers une
rémunération fondée notamment sur des
objectifs de santé publique et un
assouplissement des règles relatives au
temps de travail et cela toujours pour
s'adapter à la réalité et permettre de
répondre aux besoins d'un univers
médico-social en mutation
pour nos soignants nous devons très
concrètement leur facilité la vie dans
les exercices quotidiens dont l'exigence
est parfois la pénibilité ne sont plus
approuvées en premier lieu nous avons
seront dans la compensation de cette
pénibilité et sur le travail de nuit
dans l'attente les mesures transitoires
prises à l'occasion de la mission flash
sur les urgences se remontées
la dureté de l'exercice enchantant que
l'enjeu majeur de prévention de l'usure
professionnelle seront comme l'a dit la
première ministre hier prise en compte
dans la prochaine réforme des retraites
je me réjouis donc que nous ayons eu
aujourd'hui ce débat essentiel dans la
perspective de la refondation de notre
santé publique pour laquelle certaines
pierres importantes ont déjà été posées
je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre alors je vais
suspendre la séance juste quelques
instants pour permettre à chacun de
s'installer pour l'examen du prochain
point l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue